House press secretary Sarah Sanders out
here on the North Lawn thanks for being
here great to be with you
you know the push has been that this is
going to be about unity about reaching
across the aisle it's been a pretty
contentious few weeks how is that going
to go over look I think that's what the
American people want they like it best
when government functions and that
elected leaders can come together and
find solutions we know we can do it
because we've done it even in the last
several months if you just look at
criminal justice reform I think is a
perfect example of Democrats and
Republicans seeing a problem working
together to find a solution and the
president led that effort we can do that
again and there are a number of fronts
that we agree on and the president's
going to lay out that case tonight we
can either choose greatness or we can
choose to continue fighting with one
another and we're very hopeful and that
Democrats will want to choose right now
some work with this president to
actually get something done as you all
were out talking about unity and comedy
and and deals the president tweeted I
see Schumer is already criticizing my
State of the Union speech even though he
hasn't seen it yet he's just upset that
he didn't win the Senate after spending
a fortune like he thought he would too
bad we weren't given more credit for
Senate win by the media and Chuck
Schumer responded thanks for watching my
speech but you must have missed this
line even more empty than his policy
promises our president Trump's calls
each year for unity I mean it doesn't
sound like a great setup to to a unity
speech I look I don't think it's lost on
anyone that we have had a contentious
last several weeks I think the point
that the president will make tonight is
when we work together we can do great
things and we have a choice to make we
can either work together and fix big
problems that America is facing or we
can ignore them and do nothing so you're
talking with us I'm talking a lot of
things whether it's infrastructure even
immigration there are places where we
disagree but there are more places where
we're on the same page then there are
some of those minor disagreements that I
think we can come to a place where you
know maybe we get some of those things
worked out there are a number of places
on health care like lowering drug
pricing
that everybody can agree is a good thing
for all Americans there are a lot of
places like that that we should look for
the common ground versus fighting with
one you know State of the Union
addresses traditionally are shopping
lists for presidents they want to this
is what they want to get done this is
they tell a story about what they did
get done what they're looking for give
somebody a little at home a little
behind the scenes and how this all comes
together you have all the port
departments kind of wanting to get their
part in right how does that break down
there are way more good ideas than you
could ever have time to address in the
State of the Union the biggest thing is
taking what the most important
priorities are for the president
he's been outlining what those look like
to the team for several weeks and
building out and putting those building
blocks together and you're gonna see
certainly like you said you'll hear some
of the accomplishments that have
happened over the last two years but
then you'll also see the look forward
this State of the Union is very much
going to be about looking forward a
visionary speech of the great things
that we can do in this country also
talking about the things that have been
done one of the things the president had
talked about is Isis and defeating Isis
from his first speech second speech to
Congress now we heard from the commander
of CENTCOM today take a listen to this
back and forth I am proud to report that
the coalition to defeat Isis has
liberated very close to 100% of the
territory just recently held by these
killers we've wiped out Isis in Iraq
we've wiped out Isis that we do have to
keep pressure on this network they have
the capability of coming back together
if we don't in general were you aware of
the president's intention to order the
withdrawal of our troops from Syria
before that was publicly announced I was
not aware of the of the specific that
the announcement or we weren't consulted
before that decision was announced we
were not I was not consulted first of
all a lot of people were struck by that
that's the head of CENTCOM not knowing
that that troop announcement was going
to happen
look general mattis was fully aware as
was the president's national security
advisor and the Secretary of State other
players that are key players in that
process they were all aware and briefed
on the situation and frankly anybody
that wasn't aware that that was what the
president wanted hasn't been paying
attention the president's been talking
about this since he started on the
campaign trail three years ago this
isn't something new for this president
he's been talking about the fact he
wanted to destroy Isis and bring our
troops home and that's what we've done
and now he's also said and he's been
very clear that if there is even a peep
of coming back we will be fully prepared
to make sure that doesn't happen and
when the Iraqis push back on this big
base that's going to watch over Iran and
and be a lilypad through the region what
is the president sitting how look the
president has met with the folks on the
ground when we were in Iraq just about a
month ago
and they were very clear that they're in
a good position to be leaders in that
region and we fully anticipate that
they'll continue to do that you know the
president seems to enjoy these big
moments what is his mindset going into
this tonight and as he's dealing with a
lot of different balls in the air
the president's got an incredible story
to tell I'm he's excited to tell it he's
at an incredible and historic first two
years in office and he's the economy has
not been as good as it is in decades
wages are rising unemployment is down
the military is being completely rebuilt
there have been a number of foreign
policy wins under this president trade
policies being renegotiated he's got a
great story to tell but he's also still
got a lot of things he'd like to get
done and I think you're gonna hear that
tonight he's gonna do what I think is
gonna be a powerful speech he's in a
great mood and he feels good about going
into the days he encouraged about the
conference committee and is he going to
push to avoid another government
shutdown certainly we don't want a
government shutdown we've said that
since the beginning of this process we
didn't want the first one but the
president wants border security and he's
going to do what it takes to get it
because he knows that his biggest and
most important duty
as president of the united states is to
protect the american people and he's
going to continue pushing for and make
sure that happens
Sara we appreciate the time it's great
to be with you thank you